[Music]
from the colleges and universities of
the nation cbs television brings you the
search the search to know and understand
man and his word the search for a richer
happier life for all
i'm eric severide
of all the instruments in your doctor's
little black bag
this one is probably the most familiar
the stethoscope
it's a simple tool it has one purpose to
magnify the sound of your heartbeat so
that the physician can judge
whether your heart is comparatively
normal
it would be convenient if the sound of
your heartbeat were the only evidence
that medical science needed
to be able to tell you that your
cardiovascular system is in good shape
or if it isn't what to do about it
unfortunately the job is more
complicated than that
cardiovascular ailments continue to take
an increasingly heavy toll of american
lives a million this year
and medical science is coming to the
view
that the evidence offered by your
heartbeat may be just the smallest part
of the job
the story we want to tell you today is
really sort of a detective story and it
has a complicated plot
the killer is cardiovascular disease
heart failure as some of us call it
the victims or potential victims are you
and me
and the detectives are a team of
scientists operating at the university
of minnesota
out at gate 27 under the minnesota
football stadium
the scientific team isn't operating
alone
500 normal healthy men of minneapolis
and st paul have been serving them as
human guinea pigs since 1948.
reporting in small groups each day these
volunteers are being checked and studied
before they develop heart trouble
in time half of them may be expected to
get it in some form many of them to die
of it
it's the aim of the scientists at gate
27 to find out why
what have overwork and tension got to do
with heart trouble what about overweight
is there a heart trouble personality
what are the best ways of spotting heart
trouble before it sets in
that's the kind of thing this laboratory
headed by dr ansel keyes is trying to
find out
and let's let dr keys tell us more about
it
the facts are simple
you know the chief killer of americans
is cardiovascular disease
disorders and degeneration of the heart
and blood vessels
here are vital statistics
they show that this problem here in
america is the worst in the world
it's not merely a problem of old people
the death rate among comparatively young
men
is shocking
it's not a reflection on our doctors or
hospitals
probably our mode of life and our diet
are involved
but the trouble is we just don't know
enough about it
it strikes without warning
of ten men
we can expect five to get it
but we can't say who
or when
or why
[Music]
with limited resources of staff and time
we couldn't study all types
and we couldn't cover the whole
lifetimes of individuals
so we started with 300 business
executives and professional men from 45
to 55 years old
and to get an idea of such men 25 years
younger we selected 200 university
students
you called ben mainly today
generally 10 at a time and they had 8 10
12 stations depending on the items being
tested
some are repeated each year and some
change they start over here like this
gentlemen hello fred hello
how are you
oh my you're supposed to tell me after i
get through this meal we'll see you at
the conference right
the turkeys if i can ask
as of now there have been four deaths in
five years
one in an accident and three from heart
failure
12 men have moved from completely normal
to definite heart disease and i suppose
another dozen are getting into trouble
but this is much better than we had any
right to expect we hope it stays that
way as far as the tools and techniques
of investigation go
many are easily available
some we've had to design and make in our
own workshop here
some we've tried and put aside as we've
developed simpler means of getting the
same results
we need measurements that can be
repeated systematically
ones that are characteristic of a man
and that mark him off from others
at this stage we're sure that the
recognition and measurement of the
differences between individuals is of
first importance
for example
dr taylor has a minor challenge for you
are you ready henry
one of these men
is an olympic athlete
the other had just finished a valuable
paper on the agglomeration of fine
particles in iron ore
can you tell which is which
when you step forward carl
back in 1924 dr carl anderson set a
world's record for the high hurdles
and dick burlingame has just taken his
master's degree in the school of mines
here at the university of minnesota
the obvious point is that first
appearances may be deceptive
thank you gentlemen
and now dr taylor for one more example
this time it's a plain matter of weight
by a system of measurements that we find
useful here
one of these men
weighs four times as much as the other
judge it's a pleasure that i yield to
you
mr nelson's right
by our densitometer downstairs judge
rogers outweighs him almost four to one
but we'll have to explain that when we
get down there
well i guess we better get started head
with that key if you will judge
identification can be made in many ways
some more accurate than others
dr siemenson might more easily recognize
a man from his electrocardiogram than
from his picture
mrs foster would prefer a picture
but not the ordinary kind
dr joseph anderson might ask for a
chemical reaction before being sure
by choice as a clinical psychiatrist
dr donald hastings would rather meet and
talk with a person whose characteristics
he wanted to record
henry taylor would want his man on a
ballistic cardiograph table
dr william maloney as a physician
employs the direct methods many of you
are more familiar with
but all of us here are interested to
some degree in all the varied ways by
which we can hope to look at and know a
man
dr keys a question what are some of the
methods you use to discover the
condition of these people's hearts to
begin with
x-ray is important
even though we only see the shadow of
the heart its shape and motion tell us
much particularly when we measure them
at the back of the eyeball is the only
set of arteries that can be seen clearly
without surgery
i see and this gives you a good view of
the circulatory system
the chemistry of the blood is
complicated
but a promising lead for predicting
coronary heart disease comes from
cholesterol measurements in the blood
we're finding the blood cholesterol is
influenced by the diet
there are many indirect ways of learning
about the state of the heart and the
circulation
morning doctor
are you ready for me yet good morning
not in zero for a minute but come right
into it
we are now entering one of the special
testing rooms where the men are placed
under various conditions and their heart
reactions compared
b4
dr simonsen
you take these cardiogram readings from
the chest and the arms and the legs but
don't they all mean the same thing
basically yes dr schmidt will be glad to
explain it to you because
you see this model the human heart how
different it looks when viewed from
different directions
we'd like to see the corresponding
picture of the electrical activity of
the human heart
theoretically it should look something
like this
wire model in three dimensions
now we're rapidly developing an
instrument to do this and to give us a
direct 3d picture of the whole hearts
activity but until this instrument is
generally available we'll have to
satisfy ourselves with one or two
dimensional shadows of this picture
something like those that this would
cast on a piece of paper let me show you
that
you see pictures like these would
correspond to the various positions that
are measured on you
by dr simonson i see doctor what you
mean then is when we take these
cardiogram readings if we just took them
from the leg or from the arm or from the
chest then we'd lose up the other parts
of the heart activity
you'd miss all of the electrical
activity except that which is shown in
one of these shadows i say well thank
you very much very welcome excuse me
yes rule now
and i'll be ready for you in a minute
bye doctor thank you doctor
how much longer has mr government come
to box oh about four minutes more thank
you
mr berry is about to have an
electrocardiogram taken recording the
action of his heart while relaxed he
will later be subjected to physical
exertion and is heart tested under those
conditions
we are ready now for your first raising
address mr perry
the doctor is marking the positions
where the electrical contacts will be
made
chest slit v1
v2
v3
just did before
that's all that's so now mr barry
testing the heart before and after a
measured stress discloses many hidden
faults
that's burlingame's expired breath
filling the middle bell
that's measured too
would it get a workout uh no breakfast
it surely was
right with me doctor sure
[Music]
[Music]
but of course stresses can be of many
kinds
some less easy to measure than others
at this station combining temporarily
the duties of a psychologist with his
own function as a psychiatrist
dr hastings is taking a personality
inventory that makes up part of our
record on each man
on this test you realize of course that
there are no right or wrong answers and
we would like you to answer as
promptly and as accurately as you can
for yourself
just to be sure that you understand the
test i wonder if you'd pick out several
questions at random
um
i often check twice to see whether the
door is locked or not
true not sure or false
yeah i guess i do that all right
anytime i have a chance i'll go to a
party
no not anymore
time was when i'd
but you want an answer as of now
i
frequently have trouble making up my
mind about things
well
i don't say i can't make up my mind when
i have to but uh
well you could take this two or three
ways
on little things or maybe even
the question is do you frequently have
trouble making up your mind
all right i guess i can't deny it
the point of these pictures is to call
out your spontaneous reaction patterns
to them you can help us most by
suggesting your first impressions about
each picture
who the people are what they're doing
any story you'd care to invent about
them
i'll take this one for
instance anything anything i think of
anything you wish
well it looks
like a young wife who might have opened
a letter that she didn't want her
husband to see
um
she's sort of secretive about it
her own mail
possibly
thank you
now this picture
well looks like a young man who is
sitting high up
uh looks like he's looking out over the
city possibly from the poche tower here
in minneapolis
just enjoying the view of the city
he looks like he's giving things a
once-over
you say the man might be courting this
girl
no
but wait a minute he's got a pipe in his
mouth he's probably married to her
it's a man and his secretary
and whatever he said must have hit a
right in the teeth
what does this picture remind you of
a country kid
trying to
slip out the window
a secret way
to go fishing
will he get caught when he gets back not
if i can help
well
it's an air raid
i've seen the magnesium flares myself
now wait a minute it's
it's not married
no
he's looking out the window
something bright and good
there may be trouble in the city but
he's looking out toward the mountains
figures everything's going to be all
right
yeah everything's going to be okay
in this laboratory dr henry taylor is
preparing to take a ballisto cardiogram
the test is based upon a principle
discovered 76 years ago by a scottish
physiologist
when he suspended a bed from the ceiling
with ropes
and found that the bed would move in
rhythm with a man's beating heart
the bed here is supported on fine
springs and the record is taken of the
motion imparted to the bed by the
subject's pumping heart
dr taylor what do these records tell you
we are beginning to find that these
ballistic records
are related to age and to the state of
the heart
the true meaning of records of this kind
will only be found by
long-term follow-up studies on the same
men
let me show you how we make these
records
the recall of this table from the force
of the heart uh pumping blood is only
about three thousandths of an inch
now this tiny motion is accurately
magnified
by this optical system
the moving spot of light has to be
photographed in total darkness
the light is moving in response to the
beat of the heart
we record the heart sound at the same
time to identify the action of the heart
valves
now we're down in the densitometer room
and dr keys is about to explain how they
measure the weight of a man
since overweight apparently influences
the aging of the heart and blood vessels
it's important to analyze precisely what
we mean by overweight
for example
are we talking about fat
are we talking about muscle and bone
here let me show you how we get at this
a football player in good training may
outweigh a desk worker of the same
height by 20 pounds and still be far
less fat
the athlete's overweight is muscle
the light worker and heavy eater is
overweight because of excess fat
and these two kinds of old weight have
very different meanings
how can we decide and measure which is
which
now fat is lighter than water
a chunk of lard or suet will float
but bone and muscle are much more dense
when we weigh a man completely
underwater we get a measure of the
proportion of fat to muscle and bone in
his body
but we must correct for the buoyancy the
air in the lungs
this means we have to measure the amount
of air in the lungs at the moment the
weight is recorded under water
dick burlingame is getting oxygen now to
flush out all of the air that was in his
lungs when he was weighed
it's all collected in the metal bell
it takes seven minutes to flush out the
lungs completely
[Music]
about half the total fat of the body is
right under the skin
by comparing the results of underwater
weighing with skin fold measurements
we're beginning to learn how to estimate
the total fat
by the simple caliper
okay dick
9.2 walk
11.8
but for some time to come we'll have to
go on checking the underwater weighing
against the caliper
to find the reliability of this simple
method
what does that mean we will go on
dunking again next year doctor you go on
dunking
and each year in the general interview
we try to keep up with a man's changing
habits in a number of fields
still like apples as much as ever you
haven't got one in your pocket have you
doctor
sorry you have to pass through three
more stations you know
now physical activity any change this
last year practically no change i go in
for a mild exercise like tennis but
mixed doubles all
and so the work goes on at the
laboratory measure record compare
each man against the hundreds of others
each man against himself in years past
and years to come
how quickly does a circulatory system
react to external changes of heat and
cold
what does this tell us about the
condition of the blood vessels how
quickly does a system recover
and what information does this give us
about its general recuperative powers
what is the efficiency of arteries at
the extremities of the body and how does
this affect the rest of the circulatory
system
what relation is there between
metabolism and the condition of the
heart
search for clues
question and question again
the answers come slowly
but the important thing is that the
answers do come
and the vital store of knowledge grows
day by day we'll see you again next year
next year we hope
we nice to see you again guys
dr keys are you ready to check over the
list for tomorrow's examination
lieutenant bly
dean diehl clyde haynes dr crawford
it's been an exhausting day at the
laboratory for the guinea pigs as well
as for the scientists
500 patient citizens of minnesota and
the dedicated scientific team out of
gate 27
are on the track of a killer
as research continues the scientists are
learning more about the chemistry of man
about his personality patterns about his
working and living habits
and the effect of all these upon the
well-being of the heart
it's a long tedious road ahead
but the eventual rewards are great for
us all
so far dr ansel keys and his staff are
not ready to draw any flat conclusions
about their work there is much more to
be learned
recent evidence does seem to refute the
widespread beliefs that overweight is a
primary cause of coronary disease
but beyond that they are cautious about
predictions
it may take another 5 10 or 20 years
but someday they hope to be able to
foretell with reasonable accuracy
which men are likely to develop
cardiovascular disease and in time to
prevent it
actually it's only within
the past few centuries that medical
science has made such tremendous strides
in eradicating the diseases of man
already some of the dread killers of
yesterday smallpox diphtheria cholera
are virtually non-existent in our
country
it may be only a matter of time before
the cripplers of today
heart disease polio cancer are also
brought under control
but it's only through the continuing
search that is going on at the
university of minnesota and at
universities and laboratories throughout
the world that the answers will be found
and the hope for a better future
fulfilled
[Music]
[Music]
you